it's time for our seen and unseen
segment we reveal the stories behind the
headlines for that we turn to Fox News
contributor Raymond aroyo all right Ray
I here USA Today made an important new
hire Laura get ready for some BR
groundbreaking reporting ganette the
country's biggest newspaper publisher
has created a new category of
journalists a swift despondent that's
right 35-year-old Brian West has been
hired as the Taylor Swift reporter he'll
be reporting out of ten Tennessee's
Newsroom for USA Today covering all
things Taylor Swift watch how does it
feel to be the Taylor Swift reporter
like literally that's your title on
Microsoft teams I am still pinching
myself I just ordered the business cards
and wrote down Taylor Swift reporter but
it's the job a million swifties would
kill
for Laura I guess this makes him a
part-time NFL correspondent given that
she's practically the chief's mascot at
this this point um did he actually say
I'm pinching myself okay yes I thought
that was a I mean meant for college kids
or something do we really say
that it's absurd and look I mean you
can't be this close to a source as my
old Mentor Bob Novak said these people
are your sources and your subjects not
your friends this is too coy but it's
clickbait they're trying to resurrect
these papers they're trying to get the
swifties millions of them to tune in and
watch this guy so now Taylor Swift has
her own dedicated correspondent I guess
if you know it gets people reading maybe
that's a good thing Laura if USA Today
really wanted to do something important
they would hire a new government
interference in your life reporter for
instance it was barely reported a big
part of Biden's infrastructure Bill were
kill switches which will be mandatory in
all vehicles in
2026 yeah they claim it's a safety feat
it's a safety feature that's
automatically going to disable vehicles
when the driver is impaired or disagrees
with government policies oh did I add
that sorry yeah well but Laura who
determines when the driver's impaired
and who else has access to this kill
switch Congressman Thomas Massie tried
to defund that Amendment and killed this
last night
watch it's so incredible that I have to
offer this amendment it almost sounds
like the domain of Science Fiction the
federal government would put a kill
switch in vehicles that would be the
judge the jury and the Executioner on
such a fundamental right as the right to
travel
freely Laura believe it or not the house
rejected that amendment by a vote of 229
to 2011 with the help of 19 Republicans
so now these kill switches are going to
be in all of our vehicles in 2026 okay
this is just another reason to have like
a 1975 you know Buick or something you
just don't you don't want any of these
these cars I mean I why would they be
against people traveling Raymond pray
tell so they could couldn't gather
together uh so you can't just pick up
like we're going to go to you know
Florida tonight or we're going to go to
no they don't they don't they don't want
you to have that freedom and and you
know people are going to be able in
foreign governments like China will be
able to hack into your car and just shut
it down on their whim this is a terrible
idea and they're talking about lasers
and and breath they'd read your breath
as a driver to see if you're impaired or
not this is way too intrusive I don't
need to be surveilled when I'm driving
my car thanks a lot maybe maybe a bad
breath meter that's different but you
know I'm not sure all right Raymond uh
with the 2024 election now it's less
than what a year away silicon Valley's
already showing who they're supporting
oh yeah Laura Google may be trying to
tip the scales in Biden's favor by
burying the campaign websites of all of
his competitors in their search engines
the media Research Center discover if
you Google the phrase presidential
campaign websites which we did Biden's
website is the third result while
Trump's isn't even shown on the first
page and if you search Republican
presidential campaign websites Google
doesn't show a single GOP candidate's
website though will herd who dropped out
and Marian Williamson a Democrat did
show up and I love we we also searched
Independent presidential candidate
websites neither RFK Jr nor Cornell West
appeared on the first page and less than
1% of people go beyond that first page
when they Google something another
reason to go Duck Duck Go or whatever
any any search engine other I keep
typing in I think it's time for me to
download it because I just keep typing
in Duck dug go because I don't want to
use Google all right what else you got
put Duck Go not duck duck goose look if
you want to know why big Tech is
crashing in to help the president look
no further than his one public event
yesterday he doesn't know what is being
said and he still has not mastered a
graceful exit sir did you ask B for a
3-day
pause he po did you ask the prime
minister of Israel for a 3day
pause
Laura I love how they pull the feed
Biden wanders away so the White House
just pulls the feed because it's
inexplicable he doesn't say goodbye he
doesn't say thanks for being here the
lady says thank you and he just wanders
out of the frame I'm telling you Raymond
Raymond we have to get this product out
as soon as possible it's only tailored
to you know people who need a little
help you know we're all going to get
there at some point but just a little
you know an elder you know for a leash
let's just say what a leash or a tether
just to bring him back to where he's
supposed to be okay maybe it could be
just clear so you don't see it and
doesn't embarrass him we need to revive
Vaudeville remember the old hook just
give him the hook and pull him off
Raymond all right Raymond thank you
don't forget DVR us hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it and anywhere
else